on the mountain for the tigers will be
right hander spencer turnbull making his
2021 first start
that's his record from last year now
moran will step in after going one for
four and driving in his 14th run of the
season in game one
ran trying to bun his way on
no chance
someone's got to cover a third how about
three guys he almost uh for a moment
there looked like he was going to not
only get himself on but
he'd bun his way reynolds all the way to
third base
well now two on with two out and then
bunt hit and eric gonzalez have been
driving in runs he did last year this
year four for ten with runners in
scoring position
and the answer is to have eric gonzalez
there's one in
and moran's gonna get to third on that
double eric gonzalez coming through and
putting the bucks on the board first
yeah hurray's minor league numbers from
2019. pretty darn good 214 era 138
innings
and only 30 based on balls that is not
too shabby there's willy castro
this bat
has to get going
and he does with a base hit the other
way
take that
so willie castro's a board with a
one-out single and here's chamber
candelario
and hit into that shift evan starts the
double play wow
great to see that
[Music]
quick inning for yahoo
spencer turnbull getting ready to face
the pirate's second inning one-nothing
pittsburgh 7-8-9 hitters the one two
pitch swinging to miss nasty slider down
and in what a terrific pitch he had no
chance good play by the catcher
late movement diving down and in this is
rodolfo castro young man making his
major league debut the one-two
and he taught him a lesson there
[Applause]
harold castro
did not play in game one he's a 286
hitter no homers two runs batted in a
lot of castros
in this game
with his gloves
don't panic
got it nice yeah look at that kind of
stuff everything he does is like he's a
little older this is his first major
league start and he's quickly working
through the tigers order
but falling behind again here because he
walked the lead off man second walk he's
got to figure out
how to stay consistent evan's grounded
back to him in the first the o2 swung on
and missed fourth strikeout for spencer
turnbull so far
big out here in the third
colin moran with a bunt single back in
the first pittsburgh won the opener 3-2
and lead one-nothing here here's the
one-two to colin moran and he struck him
out spencer turnbull
dealing here in the third it's a
one-nothing pittsburgh lead
bottom third of the order goodram badou
and griner see if they can get something
started against miguel
goodroom first pitch swinging deep left
center field way back and that ball is
gone
we are tied thanks to a solo bomb from
nico goodrum his second of the year and
it leads off the tigers third
well maybe that'll think turn things
around for nico we've talked about him
having more power from the left side
and top of the order robbie grossman
flied to left in the first in there for
called third strike and grossman knew it
the curve ball from your hooray strikes
out robbie grossman threw three innings
in detroit pirates one tigers one
this is dustin fowler you can understand
why fowler squared to bunt he's been up
four times so far in the double header
and he struck out all four times the 2-2
popped up
get back grinder
looking forward he's got it
a 1-2-3 inning for spencer turnbull and
on top of that just 10 pitches
to get through those three pittsburgh
hitters good stuff
29 pitches through three innings two
base runners a couple of strikeouts
and there it is
wow
what a pitch i mean he had such a feel
for pitching if you can go back and
watch that that the only really
pitch they went after strikes on was to
get ahead with that football for strike
one
two outs for ramos six home runs for him
sure they are proud today
of watching their son in his first major
league start he's gotten through four
strong
and a 1-1 tie in detroit
i'll tell you love those one-two pitch
at bats pittsburgh's up there swinging
now the o2
did he go too far you better believe he
did
that is as good and efficient as you're
gonna find
five pitches and spencer turnbull turns
back the pirates a one two three fifth
he's been money tonight
tigers need to take the lead here bottom
of the fifth jonathan scope harold
castro and nico goodroom
scope delirious one deep
left field sia
baby how good did that feel his first
extra base hit of the season and it
gives the tigers a 2-1 lead
here's the pitch
it's a four-seam fastball
up in the zone and jonathan
absolutely greets it in the perfect spot
he knew it right away what a good
feeling that's got to be for him first
walk of the game for the right-handed
yohuri
you hear the chance of badou as he comes
to the plate
gotta keep adding on boys
the one one there goes good one swinging
the ground ball base hit into right
center field beautiful go to him around
second and he's gonna be waved around
third up with the ball polanco his throw
is to second no throw home a base hit
into right center aquila badou into
second rbi double 3-1 tigers two away in
the fifth and here's willy castro here's
the one two castro strokes one to center
that's gonna drop but dew is gonna try
and score and he will standing up and
willie castro with his second hit of the
night drives in the tigers fourth run to
make it 4-1
phillip evans at the plate for the
pirates has bounced back to the mound
and struck out
and turning that one around
brian garcia gives up a home run for
only the second time in his career
not since trey mancini did it two years
ago as he allowed a home run and phillip
evans gets one back for the pirates 4-2
tigers runner at third priority number
one get that runner home
harold castro boy did he have good
swings on sunday another one
there you go little too
and that'll drop
reyes trouts home harold castro delivers
and the tigers get that run right back
here in the six
they'll let the kid who's made his major
league debut
here tonight rodolfo castro bat against
gregory soto with two down here in the
seventh
first pitch swinging high chopper cut
off by candelario and the tigers earn a
split
the five-game losing streak is over soto
shuts the door in the seventh and
detroit wins it 5-2